en lo profundo de la selva amazónica la
búsqueda de un periodista británico y un
experto indígena brasileño ambos
desaparecidos está en marcha con philips
y bruno pereyra fueron vistos por última
vez el 5 de junio mientras viajaban por
el río y tacoa y las autoridades
brasileñas han encontrado posibles
restos humanos cerca de la ciudad de
atalaya do norte tras un lento inicio de
la investigación
este era uno de los grandes problemas
que tenía la gente desaparecieron y el
gobierno fue lento en responder en los
últimos días eso finalmente se ha
solucionado tras una enorme presión
pública principalmente de sus amigos
periodistas your best friend's out en
todo el mundo la gente se está
preguntando dónde están dom y bruno
incluso también se han encontrado
rastros de sangre en un bote la policía
brasileña considera sospechoso al
propietario de la embarcación un
pescador tanto phillips como pereira son
experimentados especialistas en el
amazonas que estaban realizando un viaje
de reportaje en la zona antes de
desaparecer recibieron amenazas de
muerte por su trabajo en el valle de
javarí donde viven cazadores y
pescadores ilegales el valle de javarí
en el amazonas es el segundo territorio
indígena más grande de brasil instamos a
las autoridades brasileñas a redoblar
sus esfuerzos para encontrar a phillips
y pereira el tiempo es esencial en vista
de que hay un riesgo real para sus
derechos de la vida y la seguridad el
presidente brasileño y air bolsonaro ha
enfrentado presión de la prensa
internacional para reforzar la
investigación después de que se
informará de que la búsqueda no había
contado con suficientes recursos